[Music]
back up the yeah retro throwbacks rarely
go for the mid-nineties mix of 2d
sprites and low res 3d models but along
comes octo path traveler a game that
manages to both faithfully recreate the
aesthetic and add to it in subtle yet
meaningful ways it's a great look one
that draws you into the world and
delights you with small artistic touches
that brings something magical to
otherwise simple and familiar
environments taking pleasure in the
dreamy diorama s look of octopus will
satisfy you for a while as will the
immediately likable combat system which
implements a few small innovations to
revitalize the otherwise traditional
turn-based battle mechanics what may
ultimately trip you up however is the
narrative a collection of eight short
stories each divided up into four
chapters of increasingly higher
difficulty after picking a protagonist
at the start of the game you gather
allies by traveling to their icons on a
map this approach is viable in theory
but octa paths woefully struggles to
weave interesting tales despite the wide
range of personalities behind them
anyhow here we are coupled with wildly
varying English voice acting it's all
too easy to want to reach for the skip
button when a story sequence slowly
winds up when engaging with story
sequences everyone but the relevant
character is relegated to being backseat
companions hidden away from view
entirely the only time your team acts as
such outside of battle is during rare
opportunities that you get a banter
notification which allows for a brief
discussion between a couple of
characters depending on who you've got
in your party
these can be entertaining from time to
time but they are too infrequent and
inconsequential to truly matter it is
disappointing to report that octopus
stories are more or less a wash but that
doesn't mean the world is any less
intriguing on its own on the contrary
it's constantly refreshing to see how
much care has gone into fleshing out
run-of-the-mill NPCs many of whom have
peculiar backgrounds that outshines some
of the more mundane major characters
octopus towns are brimming with excuses
to look twice at the unsung heroes and
villains that call you rest stops home
NPCs feature other smart interactive
touches as well that call upon your
characters individual strengths just
like you'd inquire into backstories you
can steal belongings or talk strangers
into selling what you can't steal you
can allure them into following your crew
and helping out in battle or pick a
fight with them in the middle of town
just a few of your options
[Music]
but a snow day bundle
either guy without a broad objective
steering your party across the world map
your instead guided by icons that tell
you where to pick up the next chapter
for a specific character and what level
your party should be to survive the
initial stops circle a sizeable body of
water in the middle of the map with each
round of chapters shifting ever slightly
outwards towards the edge the procession
of events and markers is measured in
such a way to provide natural progress
through each character's personal
adventure keep up with the logical order
and you may never have to grind for
experience if you avoid fast traveling
to previously visited locations in order
to activate a chapter you need the
relevant character in your party but
even if you neglect to cycle party
members regularly enough to keep them on
even footing by the time they're called
upon you can still carry a grossly under
levelled character into battle without
too much concern it's one of the many
reasons why octopus battle system feels
so fresh it's about what you hit the
enemy with rather than how hard the hit
lands every enemy in octa path is
vulnerable to at least one particular
element or weapon type and most are
vulnerable to three or more you
successfully strike with a relevant
spell or weapon and icon appears so that
you've got a clear record of what to do
down the road with these tactics in mind
your goal is to break in enemy's
defenses by hitting them enough times
with effective attacks to whittle away
their shield once broken and enemy will
lose their next turn and remain in a
highly vulnerable state where attacks
hurt them a little bit more than usual
the other important piece of combat is
the battle point system battle points
act as extra swings of a weapon in a
turn or as a means to power up magical
attacks every character gets one BP add
it to their slate per turn so long as
they don't spend any which will delete
your cruel process by an additional term
in most cases saving up BP is a
beneficial way to wear down an enemies
shield in one turn with a single
character but once an enemy is broken
BP is best used to fortify single
attacks during that window of
opportunity
the concept of breaking enemies is
paramount during boss battles long
Affairs that test your ability to remain
focused on your resources characters
turn order and preparing for surprise
attacks common enemies will pose
formidable challenges as well but those
fights go a lot quicker and you're
afforded more opportunities to flex your
various skills for the fun of it rather
than to satisfy the punishing demands of
excruciating bosses your battle party is
only as good as you make them which
means not only earning enough experience
points to level them up and learn new
skills but coordinating individual skill
sets to diversify your options as a team
while also doubling down in your most
effective attacks each of the eight
characters starts with a distinct job
and as you explore you uncover shrines
to let you assign a secondary job as
well each secondary job though is
limited to one character at a time you
will no doubt come to prefer certain
jobs over others but some of the most
valuable skills are tied to characters
rather than their particular assignments
Hana the hunter for example has a unique
ability to capture enemies that can be
summoned during future battles a limited
number of times where as alpha in the
Apothecary can make medicine mid-battle
by synthesizing salves with expendable
ingredients between these unique
character traits and a variety of jobs
on-hand your party will transform on a
regular basis to keep up with the
demands of bosses and particularly
finicky enemy types this constant search
for new strategies leads to a wonderful
variety of experiences and
accomplishments by the time you reach
octopod say
[Music]
despite the lackluster stories that play
through the world Octopus thrives on its
character progression and the
temptations of high-level challenges and
rewards the promise of new jobs exciting
boss fights and powerful gear will
inspire you to poke around every corner
and there are no shortage of discoveries
to strive for and all the while you're
treated to one of the most interesting
and effective reimagining of a retro
aesthetic around octopus will likely be
a divisive game due to its fractured
storytelling but it's one worth playing
despite its trouble tales its high
points are simply too good to ignore
[Music]